[Musik]
mit
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sally bell heute
gibt's ein kleines battle bei uns hier
auf dem kanal denn heute trittin sally
gegen timo oder briefträger ist auch
schon da dass der wechsel stichwort wir
machen heute kumpel das sind gefühlte
kartoffeln aus dem ofen wie essen wir in
der türkei richtig gerne in deutschland
gibt auch ein paar stellen wo man sie
bekommt aber eben nicht überall
das heißt ihr müsst sie einfach mal
selbst zubereiten sie sind wirklich zu
vereinfachen der herstellung und vor
allem sehr lecker und jeder kann sie
belegen womit er möchte ich habe heute
eine version mit lack schnittlauch und
einfach liberation mit suchtproblemen
oliven richtig lecker aber ich denke
beide sind super lecker aber wir werden
jetzt trotzdem dass vettel antreten
und ich würde jetzt erst einmal sagen
ich habe mich mal die kartoffel und
zeigt euch was ihr so an computern
benötigt so erst mal müsst ihr sie
kartoffeln vorbereiten ich habe jetzt
große kartoffel und da meine ich auch
wirklich besser große kartoffeln dass er
jetzt mehlig kochende unicredit vier
stück und eine davon liegt etwa vier bis
500 gramm
und das ist auch wirklich super wichtig
also nehmt einfach die größten
kartoffeln die ihr finden könnt und wie
kommen gleich in baccum vorher werden
sie aber im wasserglas damit den
backofen einfach nicht du fährst und zu
hart werden
deswegen lege ich jetzt hier in einem
großen topf braucht auch einen großen
topf damit alle reinpassen
aber das kriege ich gleich kommt halt
drauf und da kam das nicht über kommt da
kommt jetzt noch salz mit rein
und lassen die kartoffeln aufkochen und
dann 20 minuten vor kochen und im web
file zeige ich euch schon mal die
restlichen zutaten
die kartoffeln braucht 40 gramm butter
200 vom käse denn jetzt einen touch
kanal also einem kaff käse mit 45
prozent und ntt lasse mehr als die
kartoffeln nicht vorgekommen jetzt gebe
ich sie auf ein backblech und wetzel
sind offen weiter garen und zwar bei 200
grad ober unterhitze für etwas 30 bis 60
minuten ist dann einfach schauen mit
einer gabel dass sie wirklich schön
weich sind und die schale gelöst und
auch ein bisschen ab und dann sind sie
perfekt
dann kommt die leckeren käse füllung
rein und ich glaube die riesen
kopfschütteln
[Musik]
jetzt in die kartons fertig ihr seht es
auch wenn ihr mit einer gabel einstechen
sie wirklich schön weit und wie ich
gesagt habe die schale gelöst ich schon
so ein bisschen wie las jetzt hier kurz
ruhen und werde in der zwischenzeit
schon mal um käse reiben und war nämlich
immer gerne für cav käse weil der
einfach nur super schmelz eigenschaft
habt und ihr werdet vielleicht films und
es schmeckt lecker
denn der schmerz da drinnen verbinden
wir dass er den kartoffeln mit der
brutto also richtig gut
den habe ich jetzt einfach kropf diesen
tagen fällt haben nicht umsonst die
größten kartoffeln gemerkt
[Musik]
für meine wäsche und braucht ihr 200
gramm butter sahne einen teelöffel
merkel keine rote friebe eine halbe
zitrone einen teelöffel salz und
virtuellem pfeffer und chili habe ich
etwas schnittlauch und 150 haben reiter
lang für meine version habe ich hab ich
das ganze programm
dann habe ich ein viertel teelöffel salz
ein viertel zählt etwa ein viertel
teelöffel wasser das andere ein
teelöffel mensa ein fehler findet dann
habe ich natürlich ganz klar zurück bei
102 und kaum mehr sein bis zu eur
geschmack dann habe ich auf jeden fall
dabei celle dating und war es ist
ernsthaft du kannst tatsächlich bei den
taten einfach ein riesen forster
ausgesprochen ganz besonderes tier beim
trinken sagt sally sagen und natürlich
sambal olek auch nicht falsche
aussprechen sehr gut und gerne bei uns
macht es alleine weil das alles klar
ok zu besetzen battle morath gegen
verliert also denke ich jetzt tue ich
jetzt nehmt ihr euch eine kartoffel heiß
vor sich jetzt nämlich die kartoffel und
öffnet sich zwei gabeln ganz vorsichtig
ich mache gerade noch ein bisschen
anders
ich mache platten chirurgische schmidt
ein bisschen verdrücken
mit der gabel vorsichtig drückt damit
jetzt einfach auch die kartoffelschalen
nicht beschädigt denn das ist ja
sozusagen unsere form also unsere unsere
schale und jetzt nehmen wir den käse
hiermit ein viertel davon also etwa 50
gramm den lege ich jetzt hier ein
gemeinsam mit einem
mutter du musst mehr halt zu hören du
machen musst die grundsätzlich die basis
vom kopf her
volksstimme wagen etwas salz und jetzt
wird es alles schön verrückt und dann
vermischt sich jetzt die kartoffel mit
dem käse mit der butter und es geht
gleich richtig lecker ist gleich schon
wieder tiefe fäden ziehen weil ich mit
butter reihe und dann ein bisschen
käsers freut sich jeder
ernährungsberater mit der mutter
[Musik]
und dann wird die masse in etwa so aus
okay ein bisschen weiter ein bisschen
mehr sein
also ich hätte meine kartoffeln schon
mal auf einem teller und werde in der
zwischenzeit die zwiebel schneiden und
dem schnittlauch fein hacken und murat
für die zwischenzeit 1 titelkampfs
also ich habe dies bereits schon klein
geschnitten den würfel wird das letztere
einfach besser verteilen mit der butter
mit dem käse gibt es nach den wahnsinn
geschmacks gebraucht für die werden
findet braucht ihr noch mal alles
irgendwie kein öl mehr so einfach ist so
klein machen ja genug fett trend genau
aber die pfanne in diesem fall darf
empfangen nicht lehrer hätten genau
bereits eine zutaten fonds seine
kollegen
[Musik]
st
also ich tu dir das ganze gewürzt wir
sind frei
ich werde meine party mit etwas mehr
richtig passt hervorragend zum lack salz
pfeffer und chili und noch ein spritzer
zitrone
ich will mir den vorbereitungen fertig
so auch hier
also dann lasst uns das komplett
anrichten
und jetzt belegen wir ich mache jetzt
auch meinen kumpels und gässchen
sauerrahm dennoch jetzt auch mal auch
macht ihm etwas olivenöl oliven rauf
dann kommt da jetzt raus
[Musik]
dann ein paar zwiebelringe und schnitt
mir kommt braucht ihm sally ist fertig
timo hat ein leichtes chaos hinterlassen
und jetzt am ball alex bisschen vom
manstein eigentlich nicht doch komme ich
war schon ein bisschen sage okay sie
zwar nicht schön aus ist aber selten
aber ich bin sicher ist schmeckt gut
okay wir machen wir zum probieren
probieren wir jetzt gegenseitig ich will
mein server ist man voll wasser
ok ich werde sagen morath wir probieren
beide beide ok msc abstimmen zu können
ich probier mal selber ich weiß das ist
genial schritt bei frost die
freundschaft auf
guck mal wieder richtig schön
vielleicht noch schmerzen der fallen
liegst du echt leid aber schmidt so
genial und ein ende ist es auf jeden
fall mit katastrophe machen muss einfach
weiter essen also ich möchte einfach
durch ist warten auch schon alle jetzt
meins meins ausprobieren
nicht schlecht aber voll lecker da
vielleicht mal sagen für welche teams
rtl ii wo das team moral und dann könnt
ihr selber auch mal eure eigene version
machen
vielleicht habt ihr auch euren lieblings
belag wird und wenn ihr gerne noch mal
sein vettel sehen man steht am start
einfach in die kommentare
ich fand es ziemlich lustig vor allem
fehlt ihr halt wie ich hier arbeite und
wm ok also eigentlich ja einige team
gegen team ordnung genau ging es den
pädagogen wollen ehrlich sagen mein
schmeckt besser damit nicht leicht
du bist hast du ja ich mag gerne alleine
ist auch besser lecker also falls ihr
die kumpel mal ausprobiert dann wünsche
ich euch ganz viel spaß dabei und einen
großen appetit und und ich jetzt auch
einen guten appetit bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
gut
o
wie du siehst ja sagen zuschauen muss
dringend was machen meinte wolf singer
im anzug eingepackt das richtige foto
finger weißt du nicht mehr auswählen
ok